bonsoir nous sommes le mercredi 25
novembre merci de nous retrouver pour
cette nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal
comme chaque jour nous revenons sur
votre actualité locale accompagnés des
journalistes de la rédaction
mais aussi de nos invités on commence
profiter avec les titres de cette
édition
françois hollande veut aider les mères à
armer leur police municipale une
décision qui fait débat certains élus
ont en tout cas décidé de franchir le
pas vous entendrez les explications
la journée internationale des droits de
l'enfant célébrée ce 25 novembre à la
verrière les associations amnesty
international et enfants du petit pays
partenaires pour une explication autour
de contes de films ou encore de jeu et
enfin ouverture de l'exposition dédiée
au petit prince et à son créateur à
versailles
soixante dix ans après sa première
édition en france plus de 400000
exemplaires sont vendus chaque année
nous y reviendrons avec notre invité
guillaume pas l'avant et aujourd'hui 25
novembre c'est la journée internationale
de la lutte de la lutte contre les
violences faites aux femmes
nous vous en parlions hier avec sa
directrice hélène colombier l'étincelle
le centre départemental d'accueil de
jour pour les femmes victimes de
violence organisé un événement spécial
dans ses locaux situés à montigny le
bretonneux pour cette journée au
programme ciné débat et instant
bien-être et détente avec le partage
d'un déjeuner pour un moment convivial
une dizaine de femmes victimes de
violences étaient présentes
chloé émane psychologue à l'étincelle
encadrer cette journée nous l'écoutons
la matinée c'était plutôt soins du corps
image de soi voilà travail au niveau du
visage des mains cet après midi donc on
valide
un débat on va visionner la domination
masculine
c'est un moment convivial un moment de
partage à vous voilà qui permet de
penser à autre chose pour ces victimes
parce que ce sont vraiment des victimes
c'est important de le mettre en exergue
et on le rappelle chaque année en france
deux cent seize mille femmes sont
victimes de violences physiques ou
sexuelles de la part de leur conjoint ou
de leur ex conjoint
et sachez que pour en parler un numéro
existe c'est le 39 19 violence femmes
informations
enfin le vendredi 27 novembre n'ont qu'à
l'occasion de cette journée
internationale de lutte contre les
violences faites aux femmes le centre
social albert-schweitzer de magny les
hameaux vous propose d'assister à une
séance de cinéma sur le thème avec la
diffusion du film les femmes du bus 678
un film de mohamed yade
le rendez vous est de 20 heures à 22
heures à l'estaminet l'entrée est libre
et gratuite est aujourd'hui également à
la verrière était célébrée la journée
internationale des droits de l'enfant
l'association des enfants du père du
petit pays organisé cette journée de
sensibilisation en partenariat avec
amnesty international toute la journée
des ateliers animations étaient
organisées pour des enfants âgés de 3 à
15 ans avec pour seul objectif leur
expliquer que le respect de leurs droits
doit être une réalité du quotidien
un reportage signé william l tous les
enfants qui travaillent
vous avez bien sûr toi
tu te feras particulièrement dangereux
droit à la santé à l'éducation ou à la
protection ses valeurs les enfants les
connaissent et elle leur paraissent
normales mais aujourd'hui découvrent
qu'elles ne le sont pas pour tous les
enfants du monde qu'il ya des enfants
qui ont pas vraiment des droits et
qu'ils n'ont pas vraiment beaucoup
france nous on se rend compte que on a
de la chance en france qu'on fait pas
tout ça moi d'aller à l'école et on
travaille pas enfin un travail mais on
apprend des voilà c'est pas travailler
dans des chantiers mais le but de
l'exposition d'aujourd'hui oui c'est
l'attraction de conscience qu'ils ont de
la chance d'aller à l'école est un droit
mais qui n'est pas respectée parce que
justement parce qu'on ya plus de 300
millions d'enfants quand force à
travailler dans le monde s'attend une
certaine conscience de ce qui se passe
ailleurs
à défaut d'être étonné il il comprend
une fois ils sont en compétition dans la
grande salle du scarabée à la verrière
les enfants pouvaient découvrir une
exposition un coin bibliothèque mais
aussi un spectacle de contes en lien
avec la journée des droits de l'enfant
une journée pour sensibiliser les jeunes
de manière ludique tout en rappelant la
gravité du sujet ils se rendent compte
de beaucoup de choses ils se rendent
compte de la différence qui peut y avoir
parfois même sur le territoire français
ils se rendent compte de la différence
qui peut y avoir dans les différents
pays
et puis surtout ils se rendent compte
qu'ils ont des droits l'objectif c'est
pas non plus de passes que ce soit lourd
pour eux c'est qu'ils comprennent dans
le ludique on s'est rendu compte que ça
passe beaucoup mieux le message et est
véhiculé de manière différente
et puis surtout l'enfant l'intègre de
confiance il
c'est la troisième année consécutive que
l'association enfants du petit pays
organise cet événement grâce à cette
journée c'est plus d'une centaine
d'enfants qui ont pu découvrir et
comprendre l'importance de leurs droits
autre sujet à présent les événements du
13 novembre ont probablement accéléré
l'armement de la police municipale dans
plusieurs communes des yvelines les plus
y ait réclamé des armes de poing depuis
longtemps ils seront équipés courant
2016 exemple à versailles et elancourt
avec william el est fanny bourdon
à versailles les 25 policiers municipaux
sont déjà équipés de matraques de gilet
pare balles et de bombes lacrymogènes
depuis les attentats du 13 novembre
françois hollande a déclaré que les
polices
municipaux auraient la possibilité
d'être équipés d'armes à feu mais avant
de pouvoir s'en servir
ils devront suivre une formation très
encadrée c'est une formation qui est
normalement dispensée par le centre de
la fonction publique territoriale qui
est relativement onéreuse et l'objectif
est justement que tous les agents qui
n'avait pas de formation soit
complètement à même de maîtriser leurs
armes d'éviter tout accident et tout
usage non autorisé une formation et des
armes qui auront forcément un coût mais
tous les policiers municipaux ne seront
pas armés
les maires qui le souhaitent devront en
faire la demande nous avons demandé à
l'état effectivement de nous attribuer
des armes sur le stock des 4000
pistolets qui est promis par le
gouvernement depuis le mois de janvier
dernier
ce sera à l'état qui décidera il ya
défaut il faudra que la ville achète
elle même ses propres armes ce qui est
un coup supplémentaire versailles
adoptent désormais le même dispositif
que les villes de poissy le chesnay ou
le vésinet dont la police municipale et
déjà armé depuis 25 ans d'abord hésitant
le maire d'elancourt a changé d'avis
après le choc provoqué par les attentats
de janvier dernier après l'attentât
notamment de la fameuse policier
municipal qui était complètement démuni
devant les gens qui arrivent avec des
kalachnikov mais là faut être réaliste
aujourd'hui il ya quand même une
situation très particulière dans
l'ensemble de pays dont la france
voilà il faut il faut donc car nationale
c'est que de nos policiers qui eux mêmes
assurent la sécurité de nos habitants
donc il faut il faut être réaliste et
d'autres communes des yvelines reste
cependant réticent t'attrape par exemple
la mairie ne souhaite pas donner ce rôle
aux policiers municipaux
la formation au maniement des armes ne
leur semble pas adéquat ils préfèrent
éviter cela en raison peut-être de
bavures policières et noël approchent
c'est exactement dans un mois à présent
alors si vous n'avez pas déjà fait il
est vraiment temps de penser à sa liste
de cadeaux pour le père noël pour que
tous les enfants aient des cadeaux à
offrir le 25 au matin ce qui lui selon
son opération boules de noël bus de noël
pardon jusqu'au 2 décembre afin de
récolter des jouets pour les enfants
défavorisés
les images sont signés mélanie poquet et
jérémy quesada
les bras chargés de cadeaux un mois
avant le jour j valérie joue au père
noël dans ces sacs de courses il y à
bien des jouets mais elle est destinée à
d'autres enfants que son fils elle est
la première généreuse à faire un don aux
puces de noël j'apporte un petit peu de
tout des peluches des livres des jouets
pour garçons forcément j'ai vu des
garçons mais voitures ont fait du tri
dans les jeux des enfants et puis voilà
les vendre bon ça pas trop d'intérêt
donc je les donne
l'opération existe depuis 19 ans
certains sont des habitués de cette
collecte solidaire savent doit faire
deux trois ans maintenant je repère le
bus de noël donc je je sais où ils se
trouvent sur je regarde sur internet
pour repérer les dates et puis je viens
là c'est le premier jour donc je suis
présente stationné à l'espace saint
quentin ce mercredi et samedi 28
novembre pour recevoir des dons
le bus sillonnera également les écoles
du secteur du 26 au 2 novembre
un moyen de récolter des jouets pour les
enfants défavorisés de l'agglomération
s'est joué après on les redistribue aux
as yeux aux associations caritatives
locales qui ensuite font des opérations
pour les redistribuer aux enfants après
quand même toute une période où ils sont
obligés de les reconditionner de les
nettoyer il ya un très très gros travail
des associations sur cette opération
tous les jouets en bon état sont
acceptés seule restriction les peluches
qui demande beaucoup de
reconditionnement aux associations pour
des raisons d'hygiène
comme chaque année le bus de noël espère
recevoir plus de dix mille jouets pour
que chaque enfant puisse aussi passer un
joyeux noël et la redistribution des
cadeaux aux associations se fera le
mercredi 2 décembre dans une salle de la
commune de guyancourt avec son conseil
municipal des enfants et enfin après une
semaine de pause suite aux attentats de
paris du 13 novembre dernier les agents
de la communauté d'agglomération ont
repris leur mouvement de grève ce matin
une assemblée générale avait lieu en
salle du conseil à trappes
ils étaient 250 à venir dénoncer une
remise en cause de leur temps de travail
et s'informer de la suite du mouvement
pour le moment les négociations n'ont
pas abouti comme l'expliqué pascal
beaury au micro de camille lambert le
pourquoi c'est la mise en place du temps
de travail à la casse qui le président
reste bloc
sur ces 1607 heures nous avons fait une
proposition médiane à 1565 heures le
président n'en tient pas compte
le mouvement ne s'essouffle pas nous
nous sommes tous nombreux et nous nous
attendons comme sur leur président qu'on
revienne sur sa décision et contactée
par téléphone la communauté
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines n'a pas
souhaité prendre la parole une nouvelle
fois sur le sujet l'intersyndicale a
quant à lui prévoit de venir au conseil
d'agglomération qui aura lieu demain
soir pour faire entendre sa voix et
maintenant nous allons parler culture
mais aussi littérature c'est le livre
français le plus connu à travers le
monde c'est le petit prince d'antoine de
saint-exupéry
soixante dix ans après sa première
édition en france le livre reste un
phénomène éditorial mondial avec quatre
cent mille exemplaires qui se vendent
chaque année c'est le livre le plus
traduit après la bible jusqu'au 28
février l'espace richaud de versailles
présente une nouvelle exposition qui
s'appelle donc le petit prince à
versailles guillaume pas l'avant bonsoir
vous êtes le commissaire de l'exposition
est également directeur de l'agencé
événementielle ils veulent bd vous êtes
en plateau avec nous pour nous en parler
mais avant cela dans quelques minutes
vous propose de découvrir un peu plus
sur cette exposition avec ce reportage
de sephora mamani mélanie poitiers et
patrick jacques de dixmude dessine moi
un mouton
cette phrase a fait le tour du monde en
70 ans le petit prince oeuvre majeure de
saint-exupéry s'est écoulé à plus de 145
millions d'exemplaires dans le monde et
a été traduit en 270 langues conte
philosophique écrit pendant la seconde
guerre mondiale et publié en france en
1946 ont des générations dont lui et ce
qui est intéressant c'est que beaucoup
de gens l'ont lu à l'école donc et on en
une lecture scolaire mais déjà très
intéressante
et quand il se replonge des années après
pardon pour la lecture pour leurs
enfants lorsque le lisent pour leurs
enfants eux-mêmes découvre autre chose
c'est une réflexion sur la vie
l'humanité sur soi même
est-ce qu'on a un enfant ce qu'on a un
adulte est ce qu'on peut grandir est ce
qu'on doit agrandir l'espace richaud
accueille jusqu'au 28 février une
exposition consacrée aux petits princes
en partenariat avec la succession
antoine de saint-exupéry et le musée air
france toutes les facettes du petit
prince sont déclinées ainsi que les
différentes personnalités de son
créateur en personnage
qui est connu de tous donc il peut
donner lieu à pour les visiteurs à une
pratique on va dire totalement
transgénérationnel c'est vrai qu'on on a
tous cette baisse est versée par le
petit prince je connais peu de personnes
qui ne le connaissent pas et et en même
temps c'est un personnage qui méritait
d'être mise en lumière qu'on en exploite
toutes les facettes c'est ce qu'on se
propose de faire dans l'exposition et
puis aussi qu'on explore c'est le cas
d'ailleurs dans cette salle
particulièrement quand il aura aussi ce
sont les différents visages de son
créateur de nombreuses pièces originales
issues de la collection du musée art
france et pour la plupart jamais
exposées au grand public avions
gourmette carnet de vol et agendas de
saint-exupéry ce héros de guerre disparu
en mer au large de marseille le 31
juillet 1944 lors d'un vol d'observation
à 44 ans ça me exupéry et un pour les
personnels d'air france en particulier
est un est un mythe est un héros et
qu'il a dessiné lui-même la voie du
courage de l'abnégation
pour transporter le courrier qui relié
les qui relie les hommes entre le petit
prince a été l'objet de nombreuses
adaptations et ses rencontres avec le 9e
art notamment avec les célèbres
dessinateurs hugo pratt et joann sfar
sont présentés dans une galerie et dans
la crypte le public découvre le film
d'animation le petit prince
réalisé par mark osborne et ses toiles
se sont levés
mais oh j'ai joué avec moi je ne peux
pas jouer avec toi je ne suis pas
apprivoiser
et si tu apprivoise nous aurons peu en
commun de londres
tu seras pour moi unique au monde
alors guillaume pas l'avant on l'a vu
dans le sujet il ya beaucoup de choses
dans cette exposition à l'or il des
extraits de textes des propos explicatif
mais aussi un focus sur l'auteur que
va-t-on apprendre de nouveau sur ce
livre le petit prince et sur son auteur
avec cette exposition on va surtout
apprendre que saint-exupéry lorsqu'elle
a écrit le petit prince
il a écrit une oeuvre universelle et
dans cette universalité
il a montré la puissance d'un compte
parce que au départ on pensait que c'est
un conte pour enfants gallimard avait
lancé une collection jeunesse en 46 avec
ce petit prince est donc le premier de
la collection alors que moi je considère
que c'est pas du tout un livre pour
enfants c'est un arrive qu'on peut lire
à un enfant mais je pense que c'est pas
du tout un livre pour enfants ce dernier
vraiment pour adultes c'est un conte
philosophique sur la vie sur soi même et
sur ce petit personnage qu'on ne
comprend pas comme il arrive dans le
désert sur sa façon dont il évolue dans
l'histoire de ce pilote qu'on ne connaît
rien sur ce pilote et voilà et donc
c'est vraiment deux personnages qui se
rend compte et enfin conti chacun se
rencontrent en rentrant le petit prince
alors comment est né un peu ce projet
comment vous avez pensé justement cette
exposition l'idée est venue il ya quatre
ans j'ai déjà fait j'ai déjà monté deux
expositions sur
la jeunesse j'ai fait une exposition sur
pierre joubert et une autre sur pierre
probst donc des grands illustrateurs
jeunesse est venue naturellement l'idée
forcément de voilà le petit prince est
quand même un personnage emblématique et
après il a fallu quatre ans pour réunir
la succession de saint-exupéry à la fois
air france à la fois la bulle de vers ça
il fallait trouver un écrin pour cette
exposition est l'espace richaud et est
parfaitement adapté ses nouvel espace
qui vient de qui vient d'ouvrir est
vraiment adapté c'est une ancienne
chapelle réhabiliter et qui est vraiment
extraordinaire et sur 1200 mètres carrés
on peut enfin mettre en avant tout le
travail de saint-exupéry quatre ans
c'est beaucoup pour monter une
exposition telle que celle ci parce que
ça fait quand même beaucoup de temps
c'est beaucoup de temps mais c'est
beaucoup de préparation on recherchait
les recherches c'est la façon dont on va
travailler après la mise en place elle
fait six mois de six mois de travail
mais le travail en amont est très
important et puis c'est cette réflexion
qui permet d'avoir une exposition pas
fait à la hâte avec des choses dont on
avait envie de mettre en avant c'est pas
une exposition qu'on décide du jour au
lendemain des hérésies on était d'accord
il a été emballé par le projet aba tout
de suite c'est eux les premiers j'ai
contacté en disant voilà j'aimerais bien
monter une exposition sur le travail de
de votre ancêtre de votre oncle ou pour
d'autres et donc on a monté cette
exposition vraiment avec la succession
sans aucun problème ajouté partons tout
de suite et même lorsqu'on a parlé
quatre ans de l'exposition le film qui
est sorti cet été même pas prévu donc le
film s'est greffé entre temps et ce film
d'animation qui est sorti cet été voilà
et a permis aussi que le petit prince
est en avant est en avant depuis
maintenant six mois on parle beaucoup du
petit prince surtout en france
il ya des pièces exceptionnelles en
exclusivité pense notamment aux pièces
de la collection du musée d'air france
et aussi pour donner un aspect différent
parce que parfois
il ya moins de focus sur justement
l'auteur du petit prince basque est ce
que je voulais montrer c'est pas
simplement le je voulais évidemment
montré le petit prince l'histoire les
personnages mais je voulais aussi
montrer le la complexité un petit peu de
d'antoine de saint-exupéry et montrer
qu'ils avaient c'est un homme qui
faisait deux choses dans sa vie c'est
comme un pilote c'est la pilote est un
écrivain et donc de ses deux activités
et ben on retient beaucoup plus
l'écrivain mais c'est un véritable
pilote qui était dans les pionniers
l'aéropostale qui a fait l'amérique du
sud qui a fait l'afrique du nord qui
était un homme passionné qui s'est
crashé trois fois voilà et jusqu'à sa
mort sa disparition ça reste quelqu'un
d'emblématique et singulier pourquoi le
petit prince 70 ans donc après sa
première édition en france parce que en
2016 on complétera ses 70 ans elle
séduit encore les plus vielles mais
aussi les parents les plus âgés mais je
pense que dans le petit prince il n'y a
aucun message politique
déjà c'est un point très intéressant
c'est que ya pas de notion de politique
qui veut prouver quelque chose à
quelqu'un n'y a pas ça du tout c'est au
contraire une réflexion sur soi-même est
donc cette approche elle et elle est
importante et elle montre que un conte
n'est pas forcément avec des sorciers
avec des toujours des méchants avec
toujours cette philosophie du conte où
il ya toujours des règles à respecter là
antoine de saint-exupéry respecte aucune
règle
il fait à sa façon donc le seul
personnage qui est un peu méchant c'est
le serpent mais le serpent c'est aussi
l'avis qui est un petit peu aussi la vie
avec la fatalité et on rencontre des
personnages à l'extraordinaire comme le
renard la rose l'amour tout et tout est
dedans on peut dire qu'il ya un peu un
héritage liés à ce livre notamment avec
le film est il décent et vos propres oui
dans la bande dessinée la bande dessinée
a voulu rendre hommage beaucoup à
à saint-exupéry et au petit prince est
depuis longtemps il ya toujours eu des
petits dommages mais il ya eu joann sfar
qui a fait vraiment un livre chez
gallimard en 2007 quête extraordinaire
qui est vraiment belle adaptation en fin
de compte en bd du petit du petit prince
donc sur sur un certain nombre de pages
soit 130 pages donc c'est quelque chose
d'assez important et après d'autres
auteurs comme hugo pratt ont rendu un
hommage à travers un livre par exemple
qui s'appelait dernier vol ou là il
raconte que le dernier jour de vol de
saint-exupéry avant qu'il disparaisse
et il ya aussi dans l'exposition la
chanson n'a pu avoir les dessins de moÿ
bus
le dernier des cinq bus parce que juste
avant de mourir moebus c'est un dessin
qu'il a réalisés sur table graphique
c'était donc et trois pages sur le petit
prince qui l'a fait pour un hommage aux
petits princes
donc c'était un beau clin d'oeil sur le
petit prince il ya une pièce
particulière un élément qui vous achetez
le plus touché dans cette exposition par
exemple il ya deux pièces importantes
quand même il ya là de la succession
saint-exupéry on à la gourmette qui est
quand même c'est cette gourmets qui a
été retrouvé fin des années 90 en mer
méditerranée qui dit pour la première
fois on a retrouvé une trace de
saint-exupéry qui était complètement
disparu et donc et milieu des années
2000 on a aussi retrouvé l'avion des
années après donc on sait maintenant
qu'il est qu'il est qui c'est qui c'est
qu'il est s'est crashé au large de
toulon
donc on a on a la certitude que
saint-exupéry est mort voilà et la
deuxième place anecdotique qui est très
intéressante c'est donc un buste qui est
fait par contre c'est l'os et donc les
pousses de saint-exupéry qui après sa
mort a donc fait en bronze et une
stature qui représente le petit prince
avec le serpent
et donc cette statue est quand même à la
jamais été montrées c'est la première
fois quelqu'un qu'on a la chance de là
vous de voir et c'est le musée la france
qui est qui nous a permis de montrer
cette pièce unique
alors il ya beaucoup de choses dont on
ignore encore sur le petit prince ya
notamment un parc d'attractions qui
existent dans la région de moustier
ressent 540 mille visiteurs arrivent
donc en 2015 vous avez travaillé avec
lui en tout cas ne relaie l'information
de cette exposition tout à fait dans les
deux cas elle c'est un parc
d'attractions qui est basé sur le voyage
donc qui est très intéressant avec des
montgolfières avec des ballons avec des
grandes productions grand format et je
pense que si vous allez vous promener
dans la direction je pense que c'est un
parc d'attractions et on va dire un peu
plus culturelle et je pense qu'il peut
être intéressant pour en tout cas la
culture de bien d'aller faire un tour et
voir se pare donc là encore voilà des
choses à apprendre sur le petit prince
un jour ce jour eh bien merci beaucoup
mieux qu'avant d'être venu sur notre
plateau pour en parler alors je le
rappelle l'exposition se déroule à
l'espace
richaud à versailles jusqu'au 28 février
merci à vous et dans cette chronique du
mercredi alors il n'est pas question
d'environnement cette semaine on
s'intéresse au savoir-vivre français
alors des ateliers existent un peu
partout en france et notamment à
versailles ville où le savoir livre a
connu ses heures de noblesse et une
codification à travers le roi soleil
c'est mélanie poquet qu'ils en parlent
bonsoir de mélanie si on sort floral
alors sulu 14
on appelait ça l'étiquette c'était un
ensemble de codes de comportement qui
régissaient la vie quotidienne du
souverain et de la noblesse celle du roi
soleil était réglé comme une horloge
sont levés la messe la chasse le conseil
la promenade et bien d'autres et le
monarque choisissez qui de sa cour avait
l'honneur d'assister à ce moment de la
journée
un moyen aussi pour lui de contrôler la
cour alors l'étiquette et donc tous ces
moments qui rythmaient la vie de louis
xiv
mais aujourd'hui il n'y a plus de
royauté en france et pourtant le savoir
vivre est toujours d'actualité
toujours d'actualité mais les règles ont
évolué bien sûr avec le temps louis 15
l'arrière petit fils de louis xiv a
développé le repas autour d'une table
les codes de savoir-vivre se multiplient
ensuite dans les salons bourgeois du 19e
siècle
nous sommes allés à votre rencontre pour
savoir ce qu'est pour vous le savoir
vivre
c'est une forme de politesse d'attention
à ce qui vous entoure
oui si ça essayez d'être agréable avec
les gens qui bloquaient l'on a à faire
c'est d'être à l'écouté des gens de les
regarder de les écouter surtout être à
l'écouté parce que franchement il y en a
pas vous vous servir pour ainsi c'est se
comporter correctement avec tout le
monde
accepter les idées de fin du moins
accepté chacun et je n'ai pas pu être
correct quoi avec tout le monde
peut-être une certaine élégance bon
sinon détail de savoir vivre
oui plutôt au niveau d'élégance je
tairai alors nous faisons certaines de
ses règles machinalement ce qu'on les
apprend dès notre plus tendre enfance le
savoir du passe déjà par la manière de
se présenter et de présenter écoutez
france 2 r elle anime des ateliers du
savoir-vivre à versailles le
savoir-vivre repose sur c'est ce que
j'apprends sur trois critères essentiels
d'avoir une bonne présentation et avoir
un bon comportement physique
si vous voulez savoir bien se tenir et
l'expression verbale est importante
également d'en savoir bien s'exprimer
sans des way est vachement bien lire
alors on a quelques conseils qu'on vient
d'entendre c'est qu'il faut faire mais
s'il ya des choses à ne pas faire à ne
pas dire non non c'est un peu plus
subtil que ça pour vous proposer un
exemple j'aimerais d'abord vous poser
une question floral faites vous partie
de ceux qui disent enchantés quand vous
rencontrer de nouvelles personnes
non alors je ne le dit pas mais si vous
me posez la question je pense que
justement il voit pas ça ne pète la
bonne réponse
on fait bien ce que c'est la bonne
réponse et je vous laisse écouter la
raisons expliquées par france 2 r
enchanté c'est très gentil de le dire
mais c'est pas c'est parce qu'il ya de
plus élégant de plus depuis raffinés ont
dit je suis ravi ravi de vous connaître
ravid enchantée de vous connaître
mais on chantait tout court c'est un
petit peu commun alors on vient de
parler de la présentation mais les
règles de savoir-vivre s'applique aussi
à d'autres sujets comme par exemple la
tenue vestimentaire l'art de la
conversation et justement l'art de la
table mais les niveaux a notamment revu
les notions de l'art de la table
revue et j'en ai appris certaines parce
que sur les images a qui vont être
on ne voit faire notamment plusieurs
erreurs je place la fourchette à droite
avec le couteau la fourchette floral
elle se place à gauche de l'assiette est
à la mode française qui nous différencie
des anglais les dents sont tournés vers
la nappe
autre information le tranchant du
couteau et lui dirigé vers l'assiette et
pour les couverts du dessert c'est à
nouveau france 2 r qui nous explique la
cuillère voile et la liaison tradition
de douala donc à droite parce que on va
imaginer ensuite que découvert vous
redescendre la donc la fourchette
et comme sa tournée et le couteau est
également dans ce sens là pour finir de
dresser la table vous rajoutez les
verres à eau et à vin vous décorer votre
table à votre goût et ne vous reste plus
qu'à vous à 48 et vos amis à veut
s'installer avec vous mais le savoir
vivre à la française autour d'une table
jorane c'est surtout de partager un bon
repas
merci mélanie et maintenant c'est à moi
de vous poser une petite question une
petite colle pour savoir si vous avez
bien suivi vos cours de savoir vivre
est-ce que souhaiter un bon appétit fait
partie des règles de savoir vivre
alors non ça ne se fait pas surtout
quand on est reçu chez quelqu'un ce
serait en quelque sorte jugé socopa
avant même d'y avoir goûté et bien c'est
une des raisons n'est pas la seule
mélanie joie vous avez bien suivi
alors pourquoi on ne fait pas bon
appétit la raison est simple un repas
c'est un art de la table s'il est
partagé entre gens de bonne compagnie et
donc c'est bien plus qu'un simple besoin
vital alors souhaiter bon appétit
reviendrait à souhaiter une bonne
digestion il faut plutôt a par exemple
le souhaiter un excellent dîner ou un
très bon déjeuner voilà maintenant vous
savez tout sur les bonnes manières le
savoir vivre c'est la fin de ce journal
tout de suite rester avec nous vous avez
rendez vous avec sephora en allemagne et
pour une nouvelle édition du kiosque je
vous retrouve demain pour le 7 8 le
journal en direct et vous souhaite une
très bonne soirée